anybody with a functioning brain you
don't have to go to harvard business or
mit to know that america's historic rate
of inflation 31 year high is a massive
problem and it's not going away anytime
soon but for months the biden
administration they have lied they've
been telling everyone that inflation
nothing to worry about biden proclaiming
that inflation was temp uh temporary and
transitory propagandist jansaki doubled
down also calling it temporary
transitory even made a pompous remark
about the rising costs of turkeys huh
what about the rising cost of fuel the
20 25 30 bucks extra people have to use
to fill their tank what about the extra
thousand dollars they'll need this
winter to to heat their homes what about
everything they buy in every store they
go to higher prices they have to pay now
meanwhile the treasury secretary janet
yellen also tried to reassure americans
that inflation was once again as she's
been saying wrong again a temporary
problem it's the same lie they have now
been peddling for months and months but
today the federal reserve chairman
finally admitted inflation was not
transitory or short-lived in fact under
biden inflation will likely be with us
indefinitely now instead of working to
address the crisis and bringing down
costs joe is only making it worse he is
now proposing higher federal fees on oil
and gas production wow we're paying a
buck 50 more a gallon let's pay more he
just signed off on more than a trillion
dollars in new spending he's now
demanding 3 trillion more in the new
green deal
socialist welfare projects that he's
supporting it is insanity it is
unsustainable it'll bankrupt the country
we can't afford it and we're robbing
from our kids and grandkids but today
joe was there in minnesota hawking his
massive build back better new green deal
socialist spending plan that would send
inflation soaring even higher
but before giving his speech joe got
distracted by a truck and once again he
reminisced about his time as a big rig
driver which by all accounts never
happened that's at least the second time
that we've heard that tall tale and i
doubt it will be the last joe biden we
now know is an embarrassing cognitive
weak frail mess every week it gets worse
and worse it's beyond humiliating beyond
embarrassing to this country and our
enemies see it and now kamala harris and
mayor pete seemingly competing to take
joe's place at the top of the ticket in
2024 even democrats have doubts that joe
is capable of running for a second term
i'm not even sure this guy can finish
his first term now pete and kamala
reportedly hate each other they're
planning an awkward joint trip to north
carolina in order to dispel the rumors
about their rivalry but tonight there is
something much more urgent than a feud
inside the white house a new coven 19
variant is now spreading across the
globe joe biden was so concerned about
it that he banned travel from several
african countries despite calling
president trump hysterical xenophobic a
fear-mongerer racist for doing the exact
same thing
as it turns out the new omicron variant
well now we're finding out was
reportedly in europe before it spread to
africa and by the way joe is going to
what block travel from europe will he
lift his african travel ban
uh will he you know is he hysterical is
he xenophobic is he a racist fear-monger
who doesn't follow the science jen saki
care to explain take a look
before joe biden was president he said
that coveted travel restrictions on
foreign countries were hysterical
xenophobia and fear-mongering so what
changed
well i would say first to put it in full
context peter what the president was
critical of was the way that the former
president put out i believe a xenophobic
tweet
and how he called that what he called
the cocoonavirus
and and who he directed it at the
president has not been critical of
travel restrictions we have put those in
place ourselves we put them in place
ourselves in the spring but no he does
not believe he believes we should follow
the advice of health and medical experts
that's exactly what he did and putting
in place these restrictions over the
weekend hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else